welcome back to the Rich Eisen show a
new dark comedy-drama series why women
kill available now on CBS all access
starring in part the man to my right
fresh off of the brilliant HBO hit
comedy veep Reed Scott good to see you
sir thank you good to have you here
thanks man
okay so now you are from upstate New
York right Saratoga yeah says make you a
horse racing family or anything like
that or no my family wasn't involved in
it but we were certainly we like to lose
a lot of money at the track is that what
how it works real good at that you know
it gets where Parcells is up there
that's right time yeah we to see him up
there like come on you just like
strolling around and there's the tuna
right no kiddin my uncle had a box on
the finish line for maybe 30 years so we
were up there constantly you know all
the kids my talented summer jobs there
it was it was a great place to grow up
again and Parcells I think still he
lives there and he goes there all isn't
there already no that's what I believe
he is up there all the time
I love I mean in your giant fan right
okay New York Giants fan chance
well now that your cuz you're from the
air back in the day where Giants Yankees
are is the sort of fandom because they
used to play in the same stadium except
for before the Meadowlands existed
that's right and then the Mets and Jets
because they both played in Shea Stadium
my dad was actually a Mets fan
I had to convert my dad slowly over my
my youth my my my dad was a he was a
Dodgers fan like so many Dodgers fans
when they bailed
it couldn't root for the he could root
for the Yankees I came over to the hats
but my mom's family my uncle was
actually he was scouted as a pitcher by
the Yankees and didn't it didn't make it
to the show but their family was so
diehard Yankees and I grew up much
closer to that family yes so my dad and
I think in order to have something in
common with me decided that he would he
would betray everything about his inner
being right coming ankus fan so he
joined the dark side now you went to the
games here Yankees and Dodgers yeah it
was a man recently which one did you go
to again we went to Sunday night the
last game of the three okay and we
brought my son
whose four and a half he's finally he's
interested getting interested in in
baseball by the way what a great name
Conrad Scott that's Scott my dad said it
president it's like a presidential name
right he said it ticks the boxes of
Supreme Court justice or major league
baseball player so the Honorable Conrad
Scott or now batting number nine no
pouting
Conrad Scott now batting number nine
Conrad Scott pretty good okay so you and
can't you you and this Conrad Wendy
again Conrad went to the game house well
he's four though so I mean how they
loved it the whole game huh the whole
game yeah he got he was he was very
excited to go and then we got to the
stadium yes I think the size of the
stadium and we got there in the top of
the second inning okay
LA traffic yes sir and something
happened inside that somebody made a
play so you heard the roar of the crowd
and he got a little nervous and then we
got inside and he just he loved it we
were surrounded by I mean I've adopted
the Dodgers as my National League team
okay I got to see some face but I hear
you sure but we were surrounded by all
Yankees fans and the moment we sat down
Aaron judge you know took Kershaw yard
and it was just place went nuts some
place went nuts and that was just for my
son's first moment of baseball which I
was really no kidding like you're Conrad
Scott sits down Aaron judge goes yard
off of Clayton Kershaw amazing one day
you'll tell him a significance is all
that I've been telling him every day
what's the reaction of a four-year-old
is this like dad go away don't go you
know I mean Major League Baseball thanks
you for for taking your young child to a
game you also have to describe one
they'll be the only one well and he also
have to tell your child when there are
photographs or video that day that the
Yankees never wore those dark uniforms
again it was weird
yes they should be burned and sent into
the fiery hell where those jerseys go to
of course a month man and here's my
thing I was going full Costanzo cuz I
went to the day before yeah Saturday the
first pitch was like 1 o'clock it was a
billion degrees that was and I went full
Costanza by saying
this is a competitive imbalance that the
Dodgers come out in all whites and the
Yankees come out and the black polyester
I agree with it and that there's no way
that they could be comfortable CC
Sabathia is uncomfortable looking as it
is just going to the mat comes out there
in all full-on dark uniform it's a
hundred degrees out because I just
coated him in like pork grease and honey
and it cries that I think I think that's
what actually did happen based on what
happened in the fourth inning of that
game but I mean but it was great and
children have no concept of beating the
traffic whatsoever now zero zero yeah
it's just like no the game's not oh my
eight-year-old refused to turn off
Sunday night football because they are
Patriots fans it was thirty three to
three I don't think I told you this
story Chris it's thirty three to three
forty seconds to go they're well past
their bedtime he flipped out when I
turned the television off I'm like it
wasn't over yeah you know you got to see
how it ends I know well how do you think
the Yankee season ends this year Reed
Scott I hate to make too clear
prediction because it'll tend to bite me
in the ass but man we're looking so good
I know that severino's back he is on
Tuesday yeah so we'll see what he looks
like I I think the fact that we could
grind it out the way we have so far this
season I think that bodes well you know
postseason baseball thing is the
greatest thing in sports so anything can
happen we talked about that all the time
here read that in May April guy leads
off the inning against your team the
Yankees with a walk they're like okay no
big deal that happens in October
season's over
absolutely sure seed series is over it's
Game one leadoff walk let's just say
Paxton starts the series against say
Oakland okay
leading leadoff walk series silver might
as well just turn the television sets
that's what October baseball just messed
with her head I love it I love it I told
you but when we were talking you know in
the dressing room earlier I'm not even
focusing on baseball right or on
football yet I can't turn I can't split
my focus because I think this year we
got the shot I mean last year was so
heartbreaking yes
and if we could see a repeat of the
Yankees Dodgers mm-hmm
that would be fantastic I did actually
for the World Series that would be
incredible well I think if baseball
could sign for it right now
they would have a wild-card series
between Cleveland and Oakland and send
Oakland to the Yankees because that has
been their difficult yeah there's not
and then they'd have the Yankees play
Houston and then have the Yankees play
Dodgers I mean that would see and then
the Dodgers would play incredible they'd
have the Nats play the Phillies in a
wild-card game to see Bryce Harper show
up to Washington in a one gamer yeah and
then have the Dodgers wind up playing
let's just say Bryce Harper my office
like that Atlanta would play and the
Atlanta would play the Cubs with all due
respect to st. Louis but that ain't
that's not happening you spend a lot of
time in Chicago on the set of my boys
right we did quite a bit okay did you
wind up at Wrigley Field or anything
like they got real lucky we should we
shot on the grass at Wrigley it sort of
spoke to their season back then and
which was like what 2006 or 7 yeah that
we booked shooting in Wrigley the first
week of October that we booked it and
July like you got it they gave us
amazing access we were we were diving
into the Ivy we're sliding into home
plate we all the whole park door so are
you kidding me was amazing yeah it was
really diving
ivy which I don't think we were supposed
to do they got little pissed about that
but you know we while we were setting up
the shots you know we had the whole crew
there and being very respectful right of
the field but you know we all brought
our gloves and we were just taking some
BP and and goofing off in the outfield
and it was just it was a dream there's a
and you dive it in the I mean like
what's Andrei Dawson's coffee mug doing
out what's Andre Dawson he placed some
of his belongings out there back in back
in the day man that is I mean what I'll
never forget walking out there for the
first time I called a game at Wrigley
Field really ESPN yeah
and and just Charley Steiner who I was
my colleague at the time told me it
reminded that he used this analogy now
it calls games for the Dodgers that it
reminds him of the movie Blazing Saddles
how they built the town of Rock Ridge
okay
outside of Rock Ridge to make it look
Lane was like scenery like I could walk
up to the to the outfield and just shove
the scenery over cuz it looks like a
movie set Oh in the apartments looking
over the wall of ivy there I mean
they're selling hot dogs you ever deers
watch a game from up there no I don't
wants to vidya that looks amazing yeah
yes a great old park that's nice I do
like Dodger Stadium I gotta say a zoo
huh yeah there's something about it I
mean it's got a bit of history it's a
pretty decent part for it for its age I
just like the fact that it's one of the
older parks them yeah it is beautiful
when you look out when you look out over
over the right and left field people
just out there just cool it's just that
you know if you want to go to the game
tonight
you should leave there yeah yeah I'm
leaving I'm going from here to the game
well actually the Dodgers arranged our
are in Citi Field right now so Reed
Scott here on the Rich Eisen show what
was it like final day on the set of veep
what was that long man the entire last
week was was pretty emotional and it
ranged I mean some people were getting
you know a lot of Tears obviously a lot
a lot of you know hugs and thank-yous
and goodbyes Tony Hale gave me a
particularly hard time just I think
trying to get me to break what do you
mean he wanted me to cry okay everyone
was sort of crying and saying goodbye
and I just I wouldn't do it you're not a
crier oh I am I'll go there but I don't
think I could let myself do it just yet
i instead sort of adopted a mentality of
you know I was fist pumping you know
tossing the cap in the air this is
there's not many shows they get to go
seven seasons and get to go out on our
own terms right were to do what we did
in the show so I just it felt very
triumphant I loved it I loved everybody
got to work with so I broke later you
did yeah but the last week I mean when
you're when you're your last shot I
guess of that oh yeah I mean your what
was your favorite episode
of this last season no in in they have
the history of the show where you're
involved in it and I think it was season
four I believe the congressional hearing
where the have one of the panel the the
senators on the congressional panelists
so it's reading all the insults from the
emails and Jonah I just start just like
a laundry list I wish you could read
them out right now I mean I know you
know I net footage I would ask I would
ask what your favorite line that was
written for you would be but is this is
a safe this is this safe for work show
yeah sorry guys you couldn't you
couldn't do that no oh my gosh I just
loved it it was incredible
now tell me about why women kill which
is available on CBS all access yeah
right now it's a it from mark sherry who
brought Desperate Housewives mm-hmm it's
it's even a departure for him it's it's
dark like the title implies there's some
murder and some death mm-hmm it was fun
because there's three different
storylines sixties 80s and today and the
stories all parallel each other in ways
but they all sort of deviate there's
lots of twists and turns I'm in the
modern day storyline like you said I'm
out of work your honour's somehow has
convinced his wife to have an open
relationship
and it happens all the time in Los
Angeles writers just crushed but it was
really fun it was really fun because
it's all heightened and it's got this
sort of soap soap opera kind of you know
delivery to it but we cover a lot of
ground and ten episodes of television we
got to do a lot of really cool stuff and
my character in particular I mean he
starts off he's a nerd Jiri discovers
his love of cocaine and then he goes
down this rabbit hole in the other and
it all ends up with I don't want to give
anything away but sure the the killing
spree at the end is pretty great and you
can check it out on CBS all access which
is a home of a ton of great television
shows including right now why women kill
and then black and blue in theaters
October 25th
thriller film we've had a couple of your
colleagues on the show Mike Colter and
Frank L of Frank loves making fun of a
photograph of me running on the beach
with my uh with my dog Hudson he just
Frank his Frank's an alpha male just a
little just a wee just a little bit just
a wee bit yeah yeah yeah
so the veins and the muscles Ames and
the muscles are dead Frank Frank Frank
looks like a guy and sounds like a guy I
went to high school with who's asking me
like what are you doing here like that
sort of thing like I walk in the gym
class what are you doing here like
that's the sort of thing that that's a
matter of fact I think he says that to
me when he sits here on the show and I'm
like I'm hosting it Frank that's what
I'm doing here but anyway tell me tell
me about black and blue uh it's a great
I love him cop thrillers and it like
Noir is one of my favorite genres sure
this would fit nicely into the the noir
vibe uh Naomi Harris plays a rookie cop
in New Orleans
hmm I play her her ride-along partner
and she witnesses something she's not
supposed to see at the hands of Frank
Grillo and his sort of crew of corrupt
cops and she's on the run and the whole
movie takes place over the course of
about 48 hours so you're following it
you know obviously not quite in real
time but you're getting this really
dense
mmm thriller and it's and we bring
technology into it and it's a bit of an
indictment on you know some of the in
justices that we're seeing now coming
from all different kinds of you know
police departments it was a lot of fun
it's great action it - Dion Taylor man
he's a phenomenal director and our
cinematographer Dante Stefano Dee who
shot you know LA Confidential and I mean
just the man's a living legend so the
movie just looks really cool and it's in
theatres October 25th yeah thanks for
coming on read Scott thank you by the
way
since we've talked about cops and we've
talked about the Yankees the show NYPD
Blue used to feature Nick tutorial you
remember Nick totora do you follow him
on on Twitter I don't I'm not a big
social media I'm terrible here's the
thing we're gonna Christa they tell you
we're gonna get Nick here coming in
October you when the Yankees
just do yourself a favor yeah and
whatever your Eid is watching Yankee
games
you're angry moment when their Yankees
maybe not be performing as well as they
are or your it is how excited it is that
is on display but NIC tutorial on his
Twitter feed excellent oh my gosh make
sure though Konrad is is asleep when you
hit play okay
make sure that the the air the air pods
are in he's lived with me for the last
four seasons of veep oh that's fantastic
read Scott here check out again why
women kill on CBS all access in black
and blue in theaters October 25th come
back anytime but that's great to have
you that's Reed Scott right here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app